welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast i'm your
host hisham azuz and today i'm really
excited to be joined by grace as we are
kick starting a short and new podcast
series where we're calling it early on
in recruitment and we're going to be
sitting down with the recruiters who are
in their first 12 to 18 months of their
career to discuss and talk about
what have been some of their biggest
challenges
what have they learned along the way so
far advice for other people kick
starting their career and recruitment
and why we believe more people should
consider a career in recruitment
so we're going to talk about grace's
journey so far
and uh grace you've been on an
interesting journey as uh you didn't
follow the the classic cookie-cutter
journey of i don't know graduating uni
or recruitment being your first
proper job
from what i can see you obviously worked
in a few different places but more
before recruitment you progress your
career at a company called american
express which i'm sure most people will
know
and i know that a career in recruitment
is something you actively pursued and
was something you was actively motivated
to get in
but i guess where i wanted to to start
with you having worked in recruitment
yourself for coming up to phone 14
months
is like
how has a korean recruitment so far
uh compared to what you expected let's
start there
sure
um thanks for having me by the way
um
yeah compared to how i expected i mean i
would say
recruitment itself has been
amazing like i've absolutely loved it uh
which is what i was hoping so yeah all
good in that sense it's ticked every box
that i hoped it would um i would say in
terms of more the day-to-day
um
it's probably been quite different
um
more so in terms of
just how many things are happening how
many things
can go wrong
um and how many moving parts there
really are
i think it's really easy to think that
it's as simple as
i never thought it would be simple but
the basics would be
people looking for jobs people wanting
to hire a new being that matchmaker and
that middle person and i think
when you're really in
in it there are just so many moving
parts and so many parts that are out of
your control
um so in many ways amazing and in many
ways
um challenging and
difficult
yeah it's the
many parts that can't be controlled
that's uh
the difficult part right early on
exactly exactly
i guess what i always like to to ask and
i'd love to hear your thoughts on this
is
what
obviously you was really motivated to
get into the industry so i guess what
what skills or experience has
recruitment given you so far that maybe
you you least expected
i think like with this question i
because i came from quite a corporate
working environment beforehand
um a lot of those basic skills that
maybe if i had just come from graduation
i might not have had i'd already
kind of luckily been able to pick up so
that was one thing for me that was a
real kind of
um
stepping stone that i had like that
helped that transition but i think all
of those things i've massively been able
to expand on in recruitment which is all
the things you would imagine like time
management and relationship skills and
people skills um
so i was really having a think about
this when i when you mentioned it before
so i think one thing though that i i
didn't expect to get so much that i've
got from recruitment would be confidence
and
it's funny for me to say that as well
because i am actually quite confident
person so it's not something that i
didn't have before but i think that that
is one really great thing about
recruitment is that you are constantly
speaking to people from
so many different places and of so many
different
levels of where they are in that company
um and you it's a very collaborative
job so i think
that's a real big thing whether you
haven't got it to start with
and if you didn't it would be a great
thing
for youtube to build in that career but
even when you have got it it just
elevates it so much more because you
really feel kind of
everything you're doing and when things
go well it's a real sense of pride i
guess
love it
honestly the
the confidence thing is has come up a
lot when we we've done these particular
series so i'm not surprised that you you
say that i guess what i'd love to ask
you to follow up on that is
of course as you do
more of the recruitment activities more
the things that you're you're improving
at you're going to have more confidence
calling a client
speaking to a candidate
managing expectations but i'd love to
just find out
if like where has this confidence or
more confidence showing up in like your
personal life
because this is also really important
and yeah i think this is really cool
yeah i think um
just everything really in terms of
anything you're doing
people are just people right no matter
it's so easy to to look at someone and
be like i remember like the first time i
was calling uh
ahead of
whose salary expectations were north of
100k and it's like i'd never really
spoke to someone like that well probably
within amex but not only in the terms of
sending an email maybe and this time i'm
calling them because i kind of
want something from them in a sense um
and
or
or trying to sell them something i don't
really like that term of selling within
recruitment because it makes it feel
like
dirty but
it's like
i i'm basically yeah trying to sell
something to them in a sense trying to
get them excited about this job and um
yeah i think i remember the first time
doing that and it's really overwhelming
thinking
it's really easy to think especially
when you get that imposter syndrome when
it's like a new career or a new
environment it's really easy to think
i'm down here and they're up here and i
what value am i going to bring to them
and i think just having to do that
constantly and speak to people that
beforehand you may have seen in that
different light
um it really changes that so in your
personal life as well that would
probably be the same
in many ways of different people that
you're speaking to specifically and
never having that barrier of
i'm here this person's here it's like
we're all level and we're all people and
we're all human
yeah
brilliant
so i'm sure you would have heard it and
it's a really common sentence that we
all hear in recruitment which is
your first year can typically be the
hardest
i'm sure you've had experienced people
within zebra uh tell you that maybe once
or twice
so i guess
let's go and i think what's really
useful about this series is people can
listen to these who are on a similar
journey to you maybe six months in three
months and eight months in and listen
and learn and find out that
the things that you had to work through
and continue to work through um yeah
isn't just
is is the same as what they are right
because a lot of people can think oh is
it just me that
it's having to navigate all these
challenges and deal with these things so
let's go straight into like what what
has been your biggest challenge you
mentioned earlier things you can't
control there's a lot of different
spinning plates but what has been your
biggest challenge on this journey so far
in recruitment and how do you think
you've
not necessarily completely overcome it
we're always working on things but how
have you sort of navigated navigated
getting better at it or working for us
what's been your biggest challenge
i think going back to what we were
saying about the things you can and
can't be in control of
that's the biggest challenge for me it's
like it's the things you can't be in
control of i'm such a control freak in
some ways in like the best possible way
i'm also very chilled i would like to
put that out there but i'm also in the
important things i like to do things
well and i like to make things
move and progress and
there's so many
things like we say that you can't be in
control of so i think for me that's
really the biggest challenge um so
there's been times for example where you
know i've spent the time and i've found
the candidate and i've built that
relationship and they're maybe not
looking for a role and i've brought them
in and got them excited about that role
and then
they've they've
i've spoke to the client about them and
brought together it's all in progress
it's all moving along and then the
client
maybe
people go on holiday or they're not
moving fast enough even though they told
us it was this really urgent hire that
they really wanted to make which i'm
sure every recruit will understand my
frustration of um
but you're
there's yeah there's been times where
you're doing everything and it's dragged
out across such a long time period which
really shouldn't be
um
and then for no fault of your own i've
had that with like a really big head of
research role and the the woman's lovely
and we've got such a lovely relationship
now but it's really horrible when you've
you've done everything right and then
you have to be that bearer of bad news
and you have to be that middle man and
you have to
um have those difficult conversations
for me personally that is i think it
really depends what your personality
type is as to what's the hardest for me
that's me because i have a lot of
empathy and i just i hate doing that
like i
it's difficult because i don't want to
tell that person that thing after i've
supported them all this way along
and it's also difficult because
obviously you've put in loads of work
and then you don't get to make the deal
that you put the hard work in for right
so yeah i think like
the difficult thing is not being in
control of things
but i think there's an element of things
that you can be in control of and an
element of things that you can't for
example like as soon as that person gets
in that interview
you have no control of that they're only
going to do as well as they can
but at the same time
you have to remember that you can't be
in control but you can have influence so
i just always try and be
as
you know make sure i've prepared them as
much as i can for the interview checked
up on them before done just sent them
everything they need from the job spec
to extra notes to videos on youtube or
articles that are about the company that
they can maybe
speak about and think of questions to
ask them from and yeah just
i would say
that's a good way of overcoming that is
just
the parts that you can't be in control
of trying to have as much influence to
make it go the right way
nice
and i guess how do you
what do you do or maybe what helps you
not let these things affect you for too
long so so what i mean is you do all the
right things
the client has just been an absolute
pain in the ass
even though you've advised you've
consulted
you can't influence it but you've got
this candidate that's going grace like i
thought it was going to be this long
they're getting frustrated how do you
not let that then sort of i don't know
maybe affect you for a longer period of
time than it does it doesn't
you're not then in a funk for the rest
of the afternoon and you're not as
productive
like how have you got better at
like i understand what you're doing on
the parts you can influence
but like
i think that's oftentimes the hardest is
like shaking these things off
so like i don't know how have you how
have you approached that have you
navigated that when you've just had a
really difficult situation that you
can't wasn't able to influence it was
out of your control
and not let that affect you for the
entire week
i think
the going back to being control like
that's the key thing there like you are
in control of yourself and you're in
control of your thoughts and your
actions and you can choose how you react
so i mean i guess the first thing is
just being human and like in that
specific situation we were talking about
just being human and and
you know
you you can't dodge around it like it's
a difficult conversation that you have
to have and so just
you know being empathetic and being
clear and concise and
laying it all on the table as it is
because that's what you have to do
and supporting your candidate as much as
you can
and then as i say at the same time
supporting yourself and understanding
okay this is what's happened and i can
choose now how i react to this i can let
it put me on a funk and
the rest of the day will be ruined maybe
there's a week or i can choose to carry
on and continue
um my manager nick always likes to have
um
like a saying of like get the uzi out
and he's like you know if you're on that
front line
and you're shooting and everything's all
good you kind of you don't want to have
that second where you stop and you rest
and you slowly kind of reload and do
that it's like you just have to get
these out straight away something else
is probably coming something else is
going to happen you need to be like
ready to go prepared
and
and that's kind of how it is but
i think you need to look at that not in
the way of like never relax go go stop
stop stop like it it's nothing like that
it's just okay things will happen things
are always constantly moving things are
going to go up and they're going to go
down but as long as you just keep
progressing and choose to be clear and
level-headed then
everything everything will be fine in
the end and if it's not you can just go
about it the best that you can um by
being human
what a great month
have have you always been like that
where's that where have you caught with
that because that isn't that isn't
typical that is yeah
i think just um over the years i i've
just always been quite like a i'm quite
a spiritual person going to mindfulness
and into like affirmations and i've read
a lot of books and
done lots of different things that kind
of have taught me these really lovely
mindsets in my life that i then carry
into work i guess and that's one of
them's like you know
like i don't want to go into that too
much because that's not the way it's
okay but yeah
it's useful for people like one of my
biggest things
in my life and which carries into all
parts of your life is like affirmations
like the things you choose to think and
speak constantly create your future so
take that
situation for example if i'm just gonna
sit and go
i'm a rubbish recruiter my day's ruined
this is this that is that that is
inevitably
what's going to happen for me in my day
because people will pick up on that then
they'll react to me differently
i'll maybe type emails differently even
because i'm in a bad mood or you know
different things will happen whereas if
i just keep telling myself you know i'm
a great recruiter
it's
it's easy to
it's easy to think you're just
convincing yourself for something that's
not true but that's not it it's just the
fact that literally everything you think
or speak
everything else around you will react to
it right so um
yeah
yeah that's just how i think sharing
that
no i appreciate you sharing that grace
and that that will be helpful for a lot
of people i've been on my own journey
with that and i've just listened to i'm
going to put it in the show notes of
this just as a bit of a a time stamp and
we'll move this on but um yeah i was
listening to a podcast recently a really
um popular guy that i'd like to listen
to is a guy called andrew hubermann and
like there's there's literally studies
now backing this up in terms of like
exactly if people were told
a certain thing
then they will believe that
yeah and it can be this isn't just a
mental this is also a physiological
thing that can happen like you're told
that you will be able to breathe longer
in this certain context and then these
people were actually able to breathe
longer because they were told that they
were able to like it's it's crazy so
like
like that it's completely true but yeah
i mean i just think
yeah it the biggest thing i'll take from
that right that everyone i think should
really hone in on and i know i'm a big
believer in this and me and my mates
speak about this a lot is like you've
based you've you've taken full
responsibility and accountability but
the main thing that you said is like i
can choose how i react i can choose my
actions a lot of people
cannot do that a lot of people can think
the candidate did this the client did
this so i'm gonna do this so i can't do
this right but what you're saying is the
candidate could decide this and the
client could do this and i'm gonna
choose how i react to that rather than
yeah you being um the victim of like how
they are determined that's a bit like
that
when i hear stories sometimes of
people getting a job and then their
recruit is angry because they were in a
process with them and then now they've
taken another job like that's never my
mindset like i'm so happy for someone if
they've got a job and that's only going
to mean that next time they're looking
for a job they'll probably come straight
to me because we've built a nice
relationship right whereas
if i choose to be mad about that then
why would they ever want to work with me
again absolutely no i love that so what
what did what did you learn then in your
first
let's just say for because you're sort
of just past the year mark so what did
you learn in your first six months
that you wish you knew from day one
[Music]
what did i learn i wish i knew from day
one
i would say
there's so many things
it's okay
since day one
i think
for me just for me
just write everything down i i'm i'm
very much someone who kind of does that
anyway
but for me it's like write everything
down and that for me as i mean when i'm
speaking to
candidates
um
[Music]
because
i feel that when you come back to that
relationship building piece like when i
speak to candidates on the phone i'll
take so many notes i'll write everything
down
and it just means when i come to speak
to them again i've got so much clarity
on everything that was said
um it sounds quite obvious it sounds
like such an obvious one but i think
that relationship building is such an
important part so even the small things
that i've spoken to them about
next time i speak to them
i can reference it and i can you know
ask about it but also in the sense of
without just the candidates just at work
as we keep saying there's so many things
that can happen and there's so many
people you're talking to and so many
different things happening that it's so
easy to forget tiny pieces of
information so if you've got it all
there
um for reference it just makes your life
so much easier
so take that seriously yeah that they're
the things oftentimes at the beginning
you can just sort of let slip and not do
those things but you've already
recognized that
yeah like you said you can if you really
capture those moments and create that
discipline
that's going to be such valuable
information and six months 12 months two
years exactly like if i speak to a
contractor for example and
they
you know a couple days later they've got
another contract happens all the time
but six months later they might get in
touch i can just scroll back
see my notes from speaking to them i
already remember i can say oh is this
roughly your day right still yep is this
this it just makes those conversations
smoother it makes the person feel that
you you know you've listened and you
remember them
um
i just feel like it adds so much value
to relationships and on that note my
colleagues will laugh because i
talk about it so much but one note have
you ever used one note
no i use i use notion
see i love notion for like my personal
life
but i just love microsoft onenote it's
so good and no one ever uses it um
so
i am such an advocate for it especially
in that terms of like note taking it's a
bit like having
a
big notepad with lots of little tabs but
virtually um
which i guess is notion as well but yeah
i just use no i use um i use note like
knight's take and i'll just use like
notes from the iphone and mac i'll just
use that
similar to that yeah yeah but it's great
like for example
when i do calls i've got like a tab that
says chat so i'll go into chats and then
i've got literally all the tabs of
people's names i've spoken to and i keep
all my notes in those separately um yeah
i don't know how to talk about it
without like making it sound any
different to any other note taking out
i'm sure i'm assuming uh
i'm assuming you you better be putting
these notes in the crm otherwise you're
only getting a big teller yeah yeah of
course of course but i mean like the
stuff that doesn't need to go in there
we've got it all there like you know
just like personal conversations you've
had or something you don't want to block
up the crm with it's like yeah and and
also just things that aren't
conversations just other things in work
that i want to remember like my own
employee stuff or different things um
it's just somewhere that you can
just put all your stuff down out of your
mind yeah so valuable yeah yeah sort of
underestimated
and
you know i showed her
many of my colleagues and my boyfriend
and different things and and they all
love it and all use it now so i think
that about backs me up hopefully
so another another question on like
back to the beginning but super curious
on this
like
if you were to
start this journey all over again
know what you know now
how would you approach the sort of your
first 90 days differently
um
if i was to start again
i would definitely say like i
which is funny because i'm now saying
this off the back of taking loads of
notes but
sometimes i definitely get have you
heard like analysis paralysis
which is what i ever think that's like a
thing yeah but
yeah basically just just over analyzing
something so much to the point that
you're not actually taking action so
i feel that
for me
especially coming from somewhere that
i'd worked for a long time and i felt
really
like a subject matter expert and what i
was doing to coming somewhere that i
didn't it's like um
from going from primary school to
secondary school right
like it's quite a difficult feeling of
feeling like
you know nothing
and that
you can't add value to things because
you haven't got those that basic
knowledge um i feel
sometimes when there's there's so many
different
like for example where i work there's so
many different um
companies and then jobs that we're
hiring for within those companies and
there's just so much information that
you have to take in that goes back and
forward if i wanted to speak to a
candidate for example
i would very much feel that i need to go
like super prepared and kind of know
everything and fill them in everything
which to an extent you do but at the
same time
like we're saying we're we're human and
people
you know you could always say
i can come back to you with that you
know i can come back and find that out
and get back to you i feel like when i
started i sort of had a bit of analysis
paralysis where
yeah everything just felt a bit too much
and then i just was not kind of taking
action it was like blocking me so i
would say if i if i could start again
it would be like
just just let things move and let things
flow quickly and act quickly and make
decisions quickly and
go with the flow and keep things moving
and we can always come back and tick
every box and cross everything dot every
eye if that makes sense yeah so don't
focus on yeah it makes complete sense so
i'm assuming you're also saying they're
like yeah pick up the phone and just get
speaking to people rather than like
exactly exactly rather than so if i was
going to call someone about a job for
example
and i'll feel like okay all right let me
just get jobs back one more time let me
just remind myself that it's like
you know it like i've chatted to people
in the office about the roles you spoke
about it on our catch up like i know it
when if they ask me anything i don't
know i can go back and i can find out
the answer and and come back to them
it's really not an issue but i just yeah
have that kind of analysis paralysis
now totally get that so to sort of tie
that all together then what would be
your like one piece of advice for
someone who wants to get have the best
possible start to their career
i think just um
just going back to what we've been
saying about relationship building like
everything doesn't have to bring you
value like right now
every time you speak to someone
um
it doesn't have to be a deal right now
just when you're
connecting with someone and someone
feels they can trust you and have that
conversation with you with confidence
and
feels that you understand their true
need then whether or not it happens
right now they'll still come back to you
and i think that's like one of the most
satisfying
things
as well
once like when you're quite new to
recruitment that point when people do
come back to you it's such a nice
feeling because you feel like you've
obviously done something right the first
time around and they're coming back to
you
and
and a lot for me
a lot of the
wins i've had recently have been through
that people just coming back that i've
spoke to a long time ago and that's
definitely something i've learned along
the way is that everything as i say is
constantly a moving part it's constantly
evolving and going to the next part and
something that you think
has no value now will have lots of value
in future so it's um yeah i would say
spend those times build those
relationships um
i i mean i'm quite lucky because the
place that i work
we are very much like invested in that
and it's we're not super kpi driven and
we are all about you know even if
someone just comes to us for for help
with their portfolio or
uh advice about salary ranges or
something like this then we are like
encouraged to take that time and spend
that time and help those people rather
than somewhere else where it might be
like we don't have time for that you
need to call this many people by this
afternoon or you need to do xyz it's
like um
yeah i i feel very lucky that the place
that i work is is more focused on that
um but i've seen the value at add so
i can
i can only recommend that
what i take from that honestly and
i'm sure
you may disagree but i'm hoping that
your degree is like
what you've experienced recently can be
hard to see in the moment
like
right exactly so that that's the thing
and that's why this is good to know but
what i take from that grace is that the
advice is
leaning like don't get so fixated on
having that candidate tell you that
they're gonna give you their cv and be
put forward for that job instead really
lean into yeah building these
relationships asking good questions
listening understanding what's important
to these people and ultimately what
you're saying is deliver a great
experience
because exactly these yeah it all it all
comes full circle and these will be
people that you could help
in them in the medium term long term but
also help more than once
so that that's what i take from that and
that's that's great advice but as i said
it can be hard to see that in the moment
but that's why these conversations are
important
right because you've already seen that
and you're only 12 40 months in
yeah
sorry i was just gonna say i think
that's the exact perfect example of what
we were saying before about i could
speak to for four or five people
um
and then
you know
none of them
are interested and i've spent you know
like when sometimes you're on the phone
for a really long time and you just kind
of think oh this isn't like bringing me
anything now and you you spoke to
four other people okay let me try some
more did it and then
by the end of it you spent a whole day
nothing's nothing's brought anything you
could be like i'm a rubbish recruiter
i've you know what we were saying
earlier like i
um
my day's ruined i've wasted my whole day
i've done this i've done that and then
actually in three four months time
that could be like your biggest quarter
because all these people
who you spent the time
connecting with and understanding what
they really want suddenly you've got all
these jobs where it's like actually
they might not be looking but they might
now because i've got something that
ticks every box of what they told me
they wanted three months ago
honestly totally what i was just going
to say was and then we'll actually the
final question was just
like when
when when nick your manager who's done
recruitment for over 10 years say grace
it'll pay off trust me focus on this
sometimes you can you can find yourself
because i had this because i worked in a
small business and there was many
experienced people around me you can
sort of go yes easy for you to say nick
like you're getting all these
recommendations you're coming back to
you but this is why this is great right
because you're you're just over a year
in and you've already experienced this
you've already experienced the sort of
the rewards of your hard work and your
integrity and your approach in your
first three six months
so the actual like timeline of actually
uh yeah all this coming back in the
ecosystem
often times cannot be as long as people
think
right yeah and we have to trust the
process
exactly and exactly like you said i
think it is really like
i don't know i wouldn't use the word
dawn thing but it can be quite a heavy
weight on you like you say when all the
people around you their networks are
huge like they've got people coming to
them all the time and then you also
feel like what
if all these people come to them then
there's gonna be none left for me but
there are so many left for you and yeah
yeah and and like you say that
they've been doing it for a decade or so
and that's
i feel like people who find that really
difficult first year like that's a
that's going to be a massive part that's
hard of it seeing everyone else around
you do everything so easily but
these things will come in time and you
just have to keep that positive mindset
keep going and like we just said in the
future that would be you
so final question why do you think more
people should consider a career in
recruitment as a choice people should be
wanting to come into our industry why
why is that
oh i would just i would just massively
recommend recruitment to anyone now i
think because of the fact like
i think
it depends on the type of person you are
right and
if you're like me i feel that if i'm
doing a job any job
and there'll be me and somebody else
that somebody else could maybe come in
do the day's work do the birmingham go
home like that's never me i like to come
in and i like to
learn things as i go and
do things the best that i can and see
what i can find from doing it and
help other people and go the extra mile
and i feel that if you're someone like
that
like me who is maybe in a different job
where you feel like you're you're not
really rewarded for that
if that makes sense
you
like
in this type of industry you you have
commission right and
it's like
you
i don't really do you see what i'm
trying to say like yeah this is for me
like when before i got into sales
i i couldn't believe that i would ever
be in a job
where me and grace do the same job i put
in more work than her i feel like i've
done better and we get paid the same
exactly yeah getting rewarded yeah 100 i
totally understand what you mean exactly
i think like that's a massive reason why
people should because i feel like if
obviously i'm not speaking about this
coming from a graduate perspective but
someone who's more like a career changer
and there's there's probably so small i
know there's so many people out there
now doing jobs that they just really
don't enjoy that much they're putting
their heart and soul into it probably
again like me doing like shift work and
not even having your weekends your
work-life balance is terrible
and
yeah you just feel like you're not
getting back what you give and i feel
that in recruitment that's very
different like you get back exactly what
you put into it and it's a really really
nice feeling so if you're someone who
likes the challenge and you're someone
who
really
likes to go the extra mile and get the
best out of things then i would i would
just massively recommend it
but i would also recommend that you very
much look into the type of company
you're joining because i feel very
blessed that i have joined somewhere
where the culture like really aligns
with my values and it's a super
supportive and collaborative environment
and i feel that
sadly they're pro as i hear there are a
lot of places that you maybe wouldn't
find that so also be be really kind of
thoughtful and
really look into where you decide to
join
grace thank you so much absolutely love
your mindset
i'm i'm not surprised at all why uh nick
speaks so highly of you and yeah you're
gonna go on to continue to achieve the
goals that you have so thank you so much
for being part of this
i really appreciate it and i know that
if anyone wants to connect and i don't
know get help or ask any more questions
that you'd be more than happy from to
connect with you on linkedin
yeah yeah so i work in the ux and
product design space so
user research ux ui product design
anyone in that space or other spaces
then get in touch
thank you